[Applaudissements]
bonsoir ça va ça va oui dit noisette
alors doit cette wii vous êtes musicale
botte de philippe lellouche
ouais j'espère en vrai ou pas ah oui ce
compte là c'est touchant la réponse est
touchant le même resto pas du dont
pascal et sa soeur est très beau qu'est
ce qui s'est passé terrible où je te la
péter buck meilleur ami mais il n'est
pas là on a mis avant je suis pas là on
a mis non non pas du tout parce qu aux
avants 20 merde avant d'être avant
d'être ce qu'il est ce qu'il est devenu
c'est à dire une grosse main avant le
cinéma avant le théâtre avant bon le
resto tous là l'eau reste aussi oui bien
sûr qu'est-ce qu'il a fait une grosse
merde ça a été vraiment c'est vrai je
l'aï bien oui oui franchement parce que
j'ai un poids depuis quarante ans que ça
fait à peu près 40 ans qu'on se connaît
on remonte dans les années où aller vite
83 82 et
aujourd'hui la wantzenau et à melun pour
sortir les week-ends c'est quand même
les barbelés donc c'est pas c'est pas
facile donc il ya une ville tout près
qui est fontainebleau où il ya un peu
plus de jeunesse un peu plus de
brillance et de sa besace et on se
rencontre et on se connaît et on
sympathise parce que le mec est vraiment
intéressant il sait chanter c'est pas
dans ce sens là parce qu'elle sait
chauffer laissez moi finir si très léché
le fit dire s'il vous plaît donc on se
sont ceux où on se fréquente on
s'apprécie et évidemment évidemment je
tombe un petit peu amoureux d'une d'une
petite nana vraiment mignonne isabelle
et il faut des trucs et il s'appelle et
ils se disent des p'tits loups et des
petits chamaillent ensemble et moi je
suis là comme un bonnet je broyais ya
rien du tout parce que je suis un peu on
voit là et puis on part au ski et la
haute ce qui a été l'apothéose
bon j'ai le poteau rouge les u parce qu'
il pouvait un moment donné plus cacher
parce que c'était tellement épais
tellement ta copine
qu'est ce qu'on aurait dit
c'est mal l'été est de tromper bien sûr
à vos mails comme le fils de [ __ ]
[Rires]
c'est vrai vous pouvez et dire que je
t'ai laissé partir une semaine avec pas
mal mais bon c'est mon vote ne goûteront
avec philippe lellouche et là vous allez
au ski et qu'est ce qui se passe aussi
et bien ce qui se passe au ski c'est que
il se passe des trucs un peu chelou
brouster que il s'enferme dans une pièce
qui moi je les cherche et je me dis il y
en a un qui part faire les courses
l'autre cinq minutes après elle parfait
relais je me permets demi je me suis
rien faisant pas un tout petit peu naïf
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la vérité je me il a attiré de ma
confiance
ouais qu'est ce que vous lui avez dit
comment s'est passé ben j'ai été à la
frontière de devenir antisémite il ya un
moment tu vas tu avais plus de je me le
dis qu'est ce que je fais c'est à peu
près ce qui me plaît c'est pas de la
faute des juifs
j'ai respect peut pas tout non plus mais
bon là c'est où j'étais tellement dans
la crise mais je n'ai jamais commencé à
découvert qu'il était c'est en somme ce
à un moment ils étaient nus l'un sur
l'autre
est-ce que je peux me défendre
après 14h et donc l'histoire c'est fini
c'est terminé bons d'état durant un
certain temps déjà épouse depuis ce jour
là on ne sait pas qui tu es on sérénité
et on a vécu tellement de 7 mario wii
avec ma maîtresse oui mais moi dire à 18
ans à peine
on a des excuses du journal officiel bo
romain non non je sais pas j'ai apris
vrai qu'il fallait plus jamais le faire
voilà et puis après c'est effectivement
il a raison un jour j'étais le voir
puisque ont fréquenté les mêmes copains
et je lui ai dit écoute j'ai fait une
énorme bêtise que tu veux bien me
pardonner ce jour là effectivement c'est
plus jamais le même philippe ça ça
marche si la personne qui va arriver là
qui tu l'as fait il ya deux ans n'était
pas là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]